public procurement matters especially  during a recession  in the eu the purchase by governments  and local authorities of the goods works  and services they need accounts for just  under 20 percent of the eu's entire gdp  that's around 2.5 trillion euros there  are lots of people looking for a slice  of that pie but the playing field is not  yet sufficiently even for a union  committed as it is to open borders and  open competitions  greener too as meps want to build in  sustainable growth into new legislation  replacing a directive that goes back to  2004  at the same time though separately meps  are anxious to create a more even  playing field globally for european  companies tendering for public works  projects in highly developed and rapidly  emerging foreign marketplaces  if that's max of protectionism mep say  expressly it is not  more they say it's time for these  countries to play by the same rules that  they profit from when they enter the  european procurement market